[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'd
be fine without me hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Millburn I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists welcome to episode number 95
today we're gonna talk about relocating
because Ryan we are moving we got some
big news moving on out we do have some
big news we'll reveal that in a second
but first a few follow-up things Ryan
our budget episode which we recorded
last episode we recorded last time we
were in in studio and buy in studio I
mean in this conference room right yeah
I rigged the studio yeah wait a minute
this is the last episode we're gonna
record in Missoula Montana is it really
I think so man yes so we're moving
somewhere we'll get to that in a second
but follow up on the budget episode that
we just put out there here's why
budgeting is important Ryan did you know
that this is according to The Wall
Street Journal Americans spend 1.2
trillion dollars annually on
non-essential goods so man in other
words stuff they don't need right on
essential goods now some of those things
might add value to your life but the
truth is we have 300 thousand items in
our homes many of those things aren't
adding value in fact they're getting in
the way of the value of the things that
could augment our experience for a
living and so many of the things are
spending money on get in the way and
we're spending over a trillion dollars a
year let's put that in perspective
because when we say million billion
trillion it all sounds the same yeah I
mean if if you were to hear someone was
a millionaire and a billionaire we are
neither and so but we we often hear
politicians talk about millionaires and
billionaires in the same sentence right
they're not the same thing that's like
saying a thousand-aire and a millionaire
that that's the same magnitude someone
who has a thousand dollars compared to
someone has a million dollars how
different is that right compared to
someone who has a billion it's the same
leap and then
nextly visit trillion dollars so if you
were to go out and spent $1 every second
$1 $2 $3 $4 do that every second and you
don't even go to bed tonight okay Wow or
the next night okay so no sleeping in a
$1 every second or the next night I mean
you do that for 30 1,000 years you'll
spend one trillion dollars I don't know
I could go that long without sleep and
so that's how long it takes to spend a
trillion dollars in fact if you would
have went out and spent a million
dollars a day 1 million dollars every
single day since the birth of the Buddha
you still would not have spent 1
trillion dollars by now and we're
spending that every year on non
essential good so that's that's why
budgeting is important it allows you to
identify what is essential what is not
essential spend the money on the
essential stuff first like also saving
money it should be part of that
essential equation having an emergency
fund essential and that leads me to this
other article the Joshua Becker our
friend shared on Twitter this article
from CNBC we'll put a link to it in the
show notes
most Americans live paycheck to paycheck
just hearing that is staggering but I
know it's true because even when I had
good money in the corporate world I was
living paycheck to paycheck yeah me too
so 78 percent of full-time workers said
they live paycheck to paycheck which is
up from 75% last year according to a
recent report from career builder
overall 71% of all US workers said they
are now in debt from 68% so think about
this 71% 71% of people have debt 78
percent of people are living paycheck to
paycheck and I know what that's like but
even in here and it goes into depth and
even people were living with six figures
a year are living paycheck to paycheck
and that that has to do with living
beyond our means I certainly lived
beyond my means for most of my adult
life yeah I mean I don't know how other
people in this category look at it but
for me the way I would look at it is you
know if I made eight thousand dollars in
a month or actually the way it worked is
we knew what we were getting paid the
next month so you say eight thousand
that's because that's Commission Olivia
yeah yeah so let's say let's say like I
had a good Great Commission month us you
know my guy sold a lot of stuff I was
gonna
get any thousand dollar paycheck I would
spend that money before you got it yeah
and most of it the vast majority of was
non-essential I'm just talking Beck's
about this when I was growing up I
remember like literally everyone in my
neighborhood including us me and my
brother my mom we were on welfare and
and the difference is we weren't always
on my mom occasionally had a job there
are a few other people in neighborhood
who were like that but but we were on
welfare I remember people like when they
want to buy something the thing was I'm
away from I check to arrive yeah I'm
gonna wait for my check to show so we're
and I remember when the first of the
month came around member that bone bone
thugs so it's the first of them that's
what it was about like we would wait out
by the mailbox you would see people
hanging out by their mailboxes on the
first one just harassing the the postal
guy because they they were waiting on a
check and that was already spent by the
second of the month we had already spent
spent the money right and the first in
the fifteenth we would get food stamps
and and it was spent before we even had
it was spent mentally yeah
well it's funny man cuz like it makes me
think that you know when I was making
you know 20 grand a year or whether I
was making a hundred grand a year I
treated it the same exact way yeah like
I made sure to spend every penny that I
could as fast as I could
yeah that's actually a good point I
think if you're making 20 grand a year
you should treat it the same way as a
hundred grand a year but treat it I'm
going to set aside this amount for my
emergency fund right I'm going to I mean
I'm when we first walked away from the
corporal role I made twenty three
thousand dollars a year and I spy a to
charity I donated just over $2,300 is
2,340 dollars a year i I donated to to
charity because my friend told me if you
can't contribute 10% when you don't have
any money
you're still not gonna do it when you
end up having money you know if you end
up making six figures again at some
point what's gonna make you do it then
if you're not doing it now if you don't
build up that habit and it was so true
then and it's obviously still true now
and so that's why budgeting is important
because you can identify what is
essential what is not a center you can
stop living emergency to emergency stop
living paycheck-to-paycheck
and hopefully we gave you some tips
there
that will help you get back on track in
that last episode if you haven't checked
it out you can go back and check it out
this episode 94 and since then Ryan
since then I've been taking over a
hundred pills a day how's it going man
how are you feeling so I've got mercury
poisoning I talked about that I feel
pretty good man as long as I don't
expose myself to any toxins yeah that
documentary that's coming out saying a
picture of it's called the sensitives
that's sort of how my life is right now
in fact we're the place the city that
we're moving to I had to get a two-month
lease on a place because I was able to
talk someone into it thankfully I need
to make sure I'm not allergic it's not
actually allergic it's it's chemical
sensitivities my body is fighting off
this mercury poisoning and was fighting
off all the the bad gut bacteria that I
had and so it can't deal with
environmental toxins I developed
something called multiple chemical
sensitivities when I was 27 years old
and has prevented me from living in a
bunch of different places in fact we
remodeled an office here in Missoula
Montana
I couldn't even work from there because
I can't go in places with a gas mask and
record a podcast not that I'm doing that
but I also have empathy for people who
reach that terminus where oh my goodness
you have to live in a tent because you
can't be around electricity or Wi-Fi or
whatever but I can't be around certain
chemicals they they add brain fog they
give me these allergic symptoms like
watery eyes really really sore throat
bad coffee things that no one wants to
live with and it is it's depressing when
I get into an environment like that so
thankfully we we found a place and let
me rent for two months that's awesome
that's today right Oh
make sure you can get a good night's
rest and yeah yeah and repeatedly do
that
right we're gonna be difficult because
we're gonna be on the road as well but
but I'm gonna spend I think 25 days in a
month and a half there so how long do
you take it how long do have to take a
hundred pills a day
it's 112 pills a day I counted them
yesterday I take it for this six-day
cycle so it's called chelation therapy
okay so this is not like it's not a
long-term thing okay and so the thing
about detox from heavy metals is you're
also removing the good metals from your
body as you're removing the bad ones and
so I have to do like niacin and go to
the sauna and do all this other stuff
I'm also doing a ketogenic diet which I
talked about last week
I'm almost two weeks into that
I'm no longer hungry or hangry it's
weird at first when I was started first
started doing this ketogenic diet
tracking everything I'm still getting
all the macronutrients I need so you get
it's mostly fat it's like 70% fat and
then 30% protein and carbs less than 10%
carbs and so it's for every 3 3 calories
of fat you get one combined calorie of
protein and carbs carbs are and
everything man cars aren't bacon I mean
it's I have to have fewer than 25 grams
of carbs a day the reason I'm doing this
isn't to like get lean or be muscular or
whatever like although I'm leaner than
I've ever been just in two weeks
I'm leaner than I've ever been in my
adult life that's a great side benefit
what I'm trying to do is get all this
damn mercury out of my fat cells that's
where it's stored and this is helping me
do that but it's also helping me be less
hungry I want coffee less frequently
like I enjoy it more and and I had no
longer want the carbs anymore I mean I'd
say I see him but that first week I was
craving cake and I was I haven't seen
you eat cake in like a decade either I
haven't hey get a decade but I like all
of a sudden like we just in my head I
have to have some cake I have to have
some little Debbie's like I was a little
right I mean you and I were fat kids
yeah oh yeah anyway so I I've been on
that for two weeks and at first like I
it was the weirdest feeling I was so
full because I eat a lot of fat you have
to track you have to be careful not to
eat too much because there's you have a
handful of macadamia nuts and it's like
500 calories right and so you do that
four times in a day you've already had
2,000 calories you have to track the fat
really closely otherwise you're gonna
5,000 calories you're gonna gain weight
on a diet like this but the point is I'm
not trying to gain weight or lose weight
I'm trying to be healthier but I had
this weird feeling like I would eat and
then I'd be full but I wouldn't be
satisfied because I had a craving I got
a heavy carbs man herbs man yeah like
and I didn't even have that many carbs I
didn't get the keto flu like many people
got the keto flu no it's hard man like
going without rice going without but
like potatoes man it's like yeah it's
even that those those carbs that for all
intents and purposes like a good heart
yeah the good carbs you can have it and
then yeah and and Becks is doing it too
and I mean I
I've I've seen this change in her I mean
she's the fittest person I know if he's
amazing but she looks like a cover of
women's health I mean it's unbelievable
you're doing this for about a week now
and she looks unbelievable man I mean
six pack abs it's it's it's amazing and
she's same thing she feel satiated once
you get past that hump you get over the
little bit of the keto flu that you get
then which makes you feel like you have
the flu for a day or so some people it's
a week or two for me it was a day and a
half but it was fine and I've moved on
and I feel good now and I can go long
times without eating and without
cravings it's so it's so nice so I just
got the keto meter so I'm since we're
getting ready to move I'm actually
moving today I'm a boxing everything up
today after this podcast I have to go do
physical therapy blocks everything up
and then you have speech practice and
then I have to take Ella to gymnastics
and and somehow move because we're
flying to Canada at like 3 a.m. tomorrow
yeah and so I'm making it all work I'm
moving out to where we're moving about a
week before you are in between the the
Canada waves of the tour by the time
this comes out we were already been
through Toronto Ottawa Montreal and we
can't really talk about what happened
there because well it'd be illegal to
talk about the United States I notice he
picked up French oui we picked a French
okay let's see here well I had the oh
you you were I'm just really proud of
you Ryan you are now an Academy Award
nominee I know man it's crazy so are you
we just got back from the the podcast
movement conference I think there's a
fourth or fifth year they did the
Academy of podcasting Awards and
thankfully our podcast was nominated as
Best Health podcast alongside some other
amazing names we didn't win in that
category though so you're you're just
gonna have that nominee I mean I think
you should change your Twitter bio dude
you know it's a nominee Academy nominee
dude no we rightfully should not have
won that
category some great people with some
awesome people in my god / yes yeah and
so it was great we met a lot of awesome
people networked with some some good
folks out there and it was in Orange
County which I had never spent any time
in Anaheim I didn't really real I had
been there before like flowing through
Santa Ana or whatever but I didn't
realize that we were that close to
Disneyland I went walking through like
Downtown Disney little Disney City yeah
it was like consumers paradise and some
other his fireworks going off at like 10
o'clock at night out of my hotel room
like there's a building in the way but I
could see like I heard like gunshots I'm
like what the heck is going on and then
like I saw the sky lighten up okay so
thank you podcast movie nominated us
congratulations to dr. Drew who won in
our category we joined the fellow losers
from other categories like Sam Harris
Tim Ferriss and Joe Rogan so we're in
good company as losers from of the
Academy Award of podcasting but I had a
good time I'd like to spend more time
out that we didn't have enough time to
spend because we were filming something
else with Matt D Avella yeah who came
down to Orange County just help us film
some stuff for this this bag project
we're working on which maybe we'll talk
about later maybe we won't but real
quick Ryan let's talk about moving man
we we we have lived in Montana for the
last five years and 2012 we were driving
through here at the end of our our tour
for minimalism living meaningful life
driving from Vancouver BC back to Dayton
Ohio yeah I had never been to Montana
never thought about Montana and I just
knew Idaho man we woke up in Idaho and
had this 10 hour drive through a state
and I knew I'd have another like 10 hour
drive through the Dakotas or whatever
that eight hours or whatever it was I
was not looking forward to Swanton to
get back home where we'd be on tour for
so long and it was a 33rd City and we're
ready to get home and then we drive
through Montana we wake up in the
morning Idaho and as soon as you get to
Montana
it's gorgeous like one of the most
beautiful places ever been this is July
2012 so the best time to be in Montana's
early July it's amazing yeah
you just see the mountains we stopped
and got coffee yep coffee some fish
tacos we did find some fish tacos in
Missoula and I was shocked man like we
stopped and we found like awesome coffee
and we sent awesome fish tacos and when
to lay petit four for a coffee for a
city of 70,000 people right dude we've
been to cities I don't want to like call
any cities out but we've been to cities
that have two hundred three hundred four
thousand people you can't find good
coffee anywhere that's true yeah so no
that was definitely impressive I don't
want to call it Regina either I don't
think that's what like you know seal the
deal for me from this little but it did
pique my interest and then I remember we
were talking to the lady who was making
her drinks the barista baristas its
barista Oh barista and no and she was
just like a really awesome quality
person and then we were just kind of
walking around found the fish taco place
people working there we're really
awesome people driving around like it's
just man I hate to use a word vibe
because you know I hate to a get old
hippie that's just they feel hey it's
Ted a really good feel to it man there
we go so so yeah it was right off the
bat I loved it for sure yeah and I did
too and we sort of we got back on the
road we were driving down i 90 and it
just kept getting more beautiful as we
left Missoula and this first time I've
ever done triple take there's this
little tiny waterfall Hot Springs like a
warm spring yeah yeah very popular
destination for college kids especially
in the summer who are still in town yeah
and so I saw these six college gives
four girls two guys and it looked like
an Abercrombie at like what Abercrombie
tries to effect on their posters they
were skinny dipping into this into this
warm spring on the side of the highway
on the side of the highway these
muscular guys with six-pack abs and and
a bigger bench press than anyone I know
I'm sure and and and then you know these
these beautiful women who were there
your college girls and and and they're
all just jump in and right as I looked
over this is what made me did the triple
take I [ __ ] you not a bald eagle flies
overhead yeah it was unbelievable man I
am from Dayton Ohio the only place I've
ever seen
a bald eagle is on my currency yes and
and so we just sort of look at each
other but we've got to come back out
here to write to write the next book and
here's the thing you and I that entire
tour all 33 cities we were looking for
the next place to go like Dayton had run
its course it was time to graduate from
Dayton Ohio I still love it it's one of
my favorite cities of all time if not my
favorite it's my second favorite still
compare it's right up there with the
place that we're moving to but on that
first tour every time we go somewhere
we'd be like in a city and I love the
city yeah there Tucson or Seattle or
every Emin well I had never been
anywhere except like Florida Tennessee
upstate pretty much up and down that's
75 highway the corridor there yeah man
and like yeah I remember going to
Chicago like oh my gosh Chicago is
awesome I remember that so I'm gonna
move here Boise man Boise is so cool man
I wanna move here yeah it was it was it
was incredible like just being able to
get out and visit new cities and have
that feeling but man
Missoula gave me a different feeling man
I don't know how to explain it it was
like everything came together like the
things that Seattle didn't have you know
Missoula did have when it came to
community or you know whatever man like
just being able to have all the pieces
fit man like that is what really seeded
Missoula especially when we came back
and visited for a couple weeks before we
like actually decided to move out there
yeah that's September yeah September
2012 we came back out here we went
apartment-hunting we ended up renting a
cabin in the middle of nowhere for four
months to write the first draft of our
book everything that remains and that
was it technically wasn't Missoula but
we had access to Missoula pretty easily
we were two hours away from Missoula
there was one traffic light in 3,400
square miles and it was right on the
edge of this mountain it was beautiful
but it was also Montana winter and it
was negative twenty-eight degrees some
mornings or 26 negative 26 some mornings
and you're trying to keep the fire going
or whatever and it was great experiment
for four months you I wouldn't want to
live like that in perpetuity but we
found ourselves gravitating toward
Missoula because even though it's a
small town
I look at as a very big small town yeah
because it's it doesn't feel it's very
it's walkable there is
access to certain things for a place it
has 70,000 people in it it feels more
dense it feels more populated because as
soon as you the local app with them here
is Missoula is 15 minutes away from
Montana and that Nestor you drive 15
minutes any direction it's vast
wilderness Montana right it's nature but
in the city it feels it feels bigger
than than what it actually is yeah but
and then a few years later I was started
to feel the itch to leave back at 2015
in particular on the way there we had
gone through a lot while we were here
like we moved to Missoula in early 2013
after that little cabin experiment out
by Phillipsburg Montana we moved to
Missoula we started a company together
with our friend Cullen right we all
moved to this house together
asymmetrical press was the name of our
publishing company and we decided hey
we're gonna help a handful of other
authors we're not still doing that with
with other authors but we helped other
people fail just as much as we were
failing and help them sort of learn
about publishing we learned a lot about
that that the publishing business along
the way and we still use asymmetrical to
publish all of our own work and Cullen's
work as well and then from there we did
the crazy hundred city tour 2014 and
there are a few places I went that year
I mean that solidified some of my
favorite cities Salt Lake City is one of
them ya love so League Tucson Arizona is
one of them I've like st. Petersburg for
a long time
Dayton Ohio is of course one of my
favorites these these very big small
towns where like they are not big enough
to sustain a major league football team
or something but but they're big enough
that you have access to the sort of city
amenities and I generally don't like
really big cities except for one of them
yeah and we're gonna move to a big city
this time around should we should we
reveal it let's go and talk about it all
right drum roll please Sean
[Music]
alright ladies and gentlemen after five
years in Missoula Montana and 31 years
in Dayton Ohio or at least Southwest
Ohio Ryan and I are moving to beautiful
sunny Los Angeles California yeah yeah
man so I'm looking forward to it man I
am too but we both have a different
perspective on this as well and so it's
really nice we're both running to
something we both see the opportunity
there and we could talk about why we're
doing it and and and why it makes sense
what we're most excited about but it's
not just about running from the place
that we're at although I have felt that
in the year over the last couple years
so two years ago I decided to move to
Los Angeles and I haven't talked about
this publicly because I we've been
working out over the last two years
because also just over two years ago so
just over two years ago maybe two and a
half years ago now I decided to move to
Los Angeles the beginning of 20 2015 in
fact December of 2014 I was looking for
places I started looking for places
right at the end of our end of our tour
and because there were seem like there
are opportunities and and through that
process as I was looking like right as I
found the place that I wanted to live I
met Beck's I met the love of my life I
met my partner and she at the time had a
one-year-old Ella and I knew that like I
couldn't just say hey I'm movin you want
to move with me kind of thing so I said
what's more important to me is it the
opportunities and changing the place or
is it trying to make something out of
this relationship and I know it's gonna
be an unconventional relationship
because I'm an unconventional guy and
she seems pretty unconventional to maybe
eventually we can make it work so that
we could move out to Los Angeles if
we're still together or if the
relationship doesn't work then I can
always move out there if I want right
and so we started dating and then things
got more serious and we just absolutely
fell in love and throughout the whole
time I was completely honest with her
like hey this isn't where I want to live
for the rest of my life and she knew
that she was more location ambivalent
she's lived in Alaska before she grew up
st. Paul she lived in New Hampshire she
ever where she's loved has just been
committed to winter all the time and I
think she's kind of done with winter
right yeah he's 35 years old now and and
and doesn't want to deal with winter all
the time and so I've introduced her to
Los Angeles because I knew she's very
similar to me at a man the first eight
times I went out to Los Angeles you
remember that first time we ever went
there was 2011 we were out on tour yeah
man it was raining which it never rains
in Los Angeles but like the first three
times I visited that place it rained
yeah tons of traffic and you know we had
50 RSVPs for our event maybe eight
people showed up because of the rain
like they decided not to come out the I
remember I remember yeah like really
really not enjoying the place the first
few times I visited I think it was seven
or eight times for me so I was dating
someone locally there and I didn't find
the right pockets right and and that was
well I think I had this Lake stigma to
Lake I don't know if this was true for
you or not but you know LA has this
certain stereotype right yeah so I think
I allowed the stereotypes to affect how
I felt about it before I even gave it a
chance yeah I mean here so well now say
I can't I can't deal with the people in
LA I'm like there's 20 million people in
LA if you can't find the right pocket
you're just not looking hard enough and
that was me at first like I'm like oh
this I don't like this neighborhood or I
was I wouldn't drive through this other
neighborhood I'm like oh this one what
is the appeal here I hadn't found my
pockets and I also hadn't found the
amenities that I eventually found access
to and for me minimalism is quite often
about more access than ownership
absolutely if you want to go to a cryo
chamber in Missoula what do you have to
do Ryan dude you dirt isn't wanted you'd
have to buy yeah you just don't and you
know I don't have a spare $60,000
sitting around to to buy a cryo chamber
but the point is if I want to go to
cryotherapy and I live in Los Angeles
that's one thing I can do if I want to
go to a Russian bathhouse if I want
access to to great food I'll have access
to that if I want access to surfing
which I
I'm actually eager to try out I don't
know how well I will do but I am eager
to to try that out especially cuz Beck's
is super super eager to try that out
so it's access over ownership for me I
don't want to have to own things consume
consume them bring them into my life I
prefer to have access to them and so
over the last two years Beck's and I
have been working on a plan to to get
out there especially over the last year
we've really been planning we've been
asking some difficult questions
questions about our relationship and
questions about being unconventional and
and questions about not fulfilling the
status quo and we had to have this talk
last night at dinner with Ella
about about moving and it's gonna be
different for us because Ella's
biological father is here in Missoula
and he's not coming to Los Angeles I
would love for him to and we've
certainly tried it's just it's not in
the cards right now at least maybe in
the future but I didn't want that yet
that's the perfect scenario he moves out
and then we're all out there one big
happy family right
and in fact our friend Leo Bob Alta did
this and he's written about it where
when he moved to San Francisco he his
wife and his six kids well two of his
kids are from a previous marriage and so
he had to get the previous merit the
previous wife and her husband to also
move in order for the move to work for
him to go to San Francisco he's actually
out in Davis California now I believe
but anyway he moved from Guam and so I
looked at that as inspiration for me I'm
like wow if he can do it with six kids
and the former marriage anything's
possible sure but then I also realized
like that's the perfect scenario but
don't let perfect be the enemy of ideal
it can't be well it's not perfect and
I'm gonna have nothing right and I'm
just going to spite myself until I can
have the absolute perfect scenario
because perfect probably never gonna
come no and so over the last year we've
worked it out so that Ella will be out
in California for once a month I will be
back in Missoula once a month and then
backs will be going back and forth it
should be spending about 50/50 time
between Missoula and and Los Angeles
thank god the flights are cheap man hey
yeah if you get the right airline and
that's really the thing and so Ella's
not able to go on her own until she's
six it's called like a companion flight
and we've looked into all of it and so
she'll have to we'll have to
working out and we've we've put a whole
plan together in order to work this out
but it's also gonna mean the backs and I
are gonna have significant chunks of
time apart you know so now it'll be a
week or more apart and that's not great
for every relationship but we've decided
a to test it out would be we think it
might even be better for us because of
our personalities who are both
introverts for both loners we both enjoy
massive amounts of a long time and it
gives us time to look forward to being
with each other so there will be
probably a week a month that we're not
together and that will be that will be
frustrating at first because we're used
to it but I think it'll make our
relationship stronger and we've also
committed to continuing to reevaluate
and I think that's really important I
think real commitment doesn't have to do
with putting a ring on someone's finger
or signing some marriage certificate
those can be symbols of commitment sure
but the real come in our our everyday
actions are we willing to ask the
difficult questions and are we also
willing to not to not fall in line with
the status quo and the status quo is
like well you all have to live in the
same roof 24 hours a day and if you
don't then you're not a real family and
you're not a nuclear family or whatever
and and that's silly because I show my
love and appreciation not by other
people's standards but by what my
standards are yeah definitely quite
often our standards because we get to
pick our standards you and I like our
standards gonna be so much higher than
what the status quo is even though it
may not look like the status quo and so
we've had to we've had to do some
manipulation there we're moving to a
smaller apartment in Missoula and
getting rid of the house and in doing
that we you know we're gonna have free
up a little resource so that we are able
to afford having you know thankfully
it's worth two income household and and
Becks
is able to to pay for a good chunk and
then I pay for a chunk in and we're
going to have to make sure we take all
that in consideration that's why
budgeting is so important you have to be
able to look at the finances honestly
can I still contribute the way I want to
contribute can I still save for my
future self for retirement the same way
I want to say
those first as priorities and then can I
afford moving to a new place and then
what other opportunities does that bring
with it you know quite often people move
to a new city because they they move to
Providence Rhode Island because they got
a job there right right and part of that
is well maybe this job will allow me to
afford living in this different city
right if we we come from what is the
second most affordable city in the
country Dayton Ohio right Canton Ohio is
the only city that's more affordable and
and so we are used to a really low cost
living and moving to Missoula I remember
was a big staff oh yeah hey dude your
rent goes up considerably yes
and then goes up again going to Los
Angeles yeah and you have to take that
into consideration but then you also
talked talked about why you're you're
making that move and sure there are some
things I'm excited about I'm really
excited that I get to walk a lot I mean
it's sunny all the time 72 degrees love
it man yeah yeah every day every time
I'm in LA do I usually put in about yeah
15 18 thousand steps yeah and Yammer
Ryan I love to walk so no it's
especially the neighborhood were moving
to everything was is within walking
distance I mean you know if I want to go
surfing or if I want to go snowboarding
or if I want to I need to get to
Pasadena or something like I'm gonna
have to get into a car but and that's
why it's known as a car sitting right
but but for all intents and purposes
like I really won't have to drive that
much I think you'll go weeks without
using your car right because because of
the location or I shouldn't say without
I said using your car very little right
because hey there's public transit and
but be it's so walkable and even bikable
if if you're willing to brave it and
they're doing a lot more to make the
city of Los Angeles a lot more bike
friendly and of course a lot more metro
friendly as well I mean the metro line
expansions that they're putting in there
are amazing you see their plans
especially with 2028 coming because the
Olympics are gonna come there in 2028
yeah they're doing some amazing
expansion on the metro lines they just
moved the expo line out to Santa Monica
so you can theoretically get from
Pasadena to Santa Monica on you know
public transportation yeah on the Metro
not just taking buses and so the reason
that we're going out there is were
we're building a podcast in film studio
and we want to be able to create more
meaningful creations not not just
content creation we're not going out
there to create more content we're going
out there - in fact I'm becoming
allergic to that word content eyes hear
it so much it just means like it sound
it's like the same word is busy to me
like I'm makings yeah I guess when we
say content though like I mean the
connotation is for me is meaningful
creations right and that's why I've
checked myself recently instead of
saying content I've been saying
creations yeah I know I say content
occasionally because it's in the the
lexicon of of the internet and so I I
certainly say but I prefer to say
meaningful creations because it's it's
more to look and it's more deliberate
and that's what we're trying to do with
the podcast and film studio is create
more deliberate creation yeah we want to
tell more stories and like here in
Missoula um it is great for writing I
think although you've mentioned to me
how you kind of become stagnant with
writing not not stagnant but not as
inspired I guess as when we first moved
out here to Montana but what I'll say is
when it comes to film it's gonna be
amazing to have Matt D Avella in the
same city with us yes we're gonna have a
lot more resources better resources to
create some very very meaningful content
with a different vehicle that you know
the the the only video we've done is the
documentary yeah pretty much
and yeah that's something that I really
look forward to minutes creating more
more video work and I think yeah having
our podcast studio having Matt out there
and having access to that pocket of
people to that community that we've
built up over the last couple years
that's really going to yeah just help us
get our message out to more people it's
funny man I remember when I first
started just even wanting to break away
from the corporate world like not just
wanting to but like dreading going to
work like I'm on my way to work sitting
in traffic on on 7575 driving from
Dayton Ohio to Cincinnati talked about
trout I know people complain about
traffic and in LA and I totally get it
there is certainly traffic there there's
traffic everywhere there's traffic
have you been to Atlanta
you've been to Seattle up the i-5 in
Seattle cog oh my goodness me yeah
that's all yeah there's traffic
everywhere have you been to Cincinnati
at 8:00 a.m. and one day oh my god it's
some of the worst traffic in the country
of Cincinnati yeah but I remember
thinking I was like man if I could just
find a way to add value to millions of
people's lives I don't care if I'm
living in a tent I don't care if I am
living in a mansion but I really want to
do something meaningful with my time and
I want to I want to affect people in a
positive way because that's the one
thing that I really loved about managing
salespeople is that you know I could
affect their moods I could inspire them
and yeah I felt like that was the one
thing that I could hopefully translate
to something else and here we are man
like we are dude we reach millions of
people every single year and it's
awesome and I think moving out to LA
we're gonna be able to reach even more
people and help ya and hope that much
more I was talking to rob bell before
our podcast with him he did a he was on
we were on his show a few years ago
before we even had a podcast and and
then he was on our podcast episode 83
just a few months ago and our live event
in Los Angeles and I told him hey we're
we're getting ready to move out to Los
Angeles this fall and he just looked him
in he said hurry I'm like what do you
mean hurry he's like you're not gonna
believe the opportunity to open up what
you get out here the people that you
meet and it's so true like we were just
at that podcasting conference a podcast
movement well for the academy of
podcasting Awards and I instantly met a
guy who was like yeah I'm open up this
this comedy venue in Los Angeles and it
seats like 2 or 300 people and would
love for the minimalist to come through
and you get all of these opportunities
instantly once you get out there that's
really what what Rob was saying I was
talking to him about why did you move he
came he move from the Midwest he's from
Grand Rapids and and and he moved out to
California you see in his he always he's
able to like have these little pithy
answers all the time you know he goes
why does ask myself where do people go
to tell stories yeah and there's no
question that it's Los Angeles and
that's what we want to do and not just
continue to tell our story but but use
the the medium of writing and film and
podcasting to illuminate other people's
stories in a unique way a meaningful way
to have creations that will stand
test of time that will help people the
same way our documentary did and I think
la is that the the next ideal step but
you I've also talked about this Ryan it
doesn't mean that's what we're gonna go
forever I may end up living there for
the rest of my life it may be a
year-long experiment and after a year
we're like that was great and now let's
move to Boise or whatever and we get to
decide that and that's really cool this
is the next chapter yeah and and that
next chapter can be as long or as short
as as we decide and we'll plan
accordingly yeah I can't wait man you
know Missoula is it's a great place to
settle but I'm just I'm not ready to
settle yet man and I want to give LA a
couple years at least and see how it
goes and like you said dude if I hate it
after the first year I can always come
back to Missoula yeah or somewhere else
yeah exactly like I'm not I'm not pigeon
holed into into stayin anywhere
this is also the beauty of not having a
huge mortgage hanging over someone's
head yeah you could turn your life
around on the dime pretty easily that's
what their accepts us to like here's the
thing if I know like for example like
say I wanted to retire and just go right
for the rest of my life I'd probably go
live in Dayton Ohio right
just because cost of living is cheap
it's a great city yes yeah yeah and and
and it's just one of my favorites I know
so many people there it's very
blue-collar it's the there's no
pretentiousness whatsoever there and and
that city for me like I could go I could
go live there and settle and feel good
about that yeah but right now it's not
time to settle it's not yeah I feel like
I can and I would get a mortgage then
two or not not a full more I would buy a
house sure maybe I'd get a mortgage
where if I had 50% down right we've
already talked about all this I'm not
going to rehash all of our budgeting
recommendations but they're like if you
know you're gonna be somewhere for me
it's at least seven years at least yeah
yeah and so the breakeven points usually
about five years but Derek Siver's says
you renting a houses is purchasing the
ability the ability to move right and
and depending on where you're at so you
know sometimes easy to sell houses but
it's always a gamble right yeah I mean
it took you you were you're a Missoula
for what two years before you able to
sell your condo that was in Dayton yeah
it was crazy and still took a huge long
song huge loss yeah he had to use like
savings to to get rid of yes and so it's
a lesson you learned and it's not a
lesson we want to I mean we we learn you
know the kid puts the hand on the stove
and and we get burned or ella was her
her biological father has a dog and she
was you know roughing it up and she'd
get stitches this weekend because the
dog eventually who's the nicest dog in
the world decided to to bite back so to
speak and she got bit by a dog right
over I oh I saw that on Instagram the
stitches yeah yeah yeah so show me that
Wow yeah and and it's the nicest dog in
the world it's just like you can't choke
a dog out until its gonna defend itself
of them yeah yeah yeah so she's totally
fine in fact she quote I thought we were
at the hospital together and her quote I
love stitches cuz afterward she got a
purple popsicle oh and we very rarely
give her sugar but they give her you
know this purple popsicle and all of a
sudden to get stitches every week Wow
anyway so I'm really excited about
getting out there the opportunities we
have the access to things like the
Russian bathhouse or cryotherapy or the
stretch lab the physical therapists I go
to out there who you know he's a
physical therapist and in a personal
trainer but he also does stand-up comedy
does open mikes up in the valley and
that's the one thing I'm looking forward
to too like there are those
opportunities here in Missoula but a lot
more opportunity in LA they're readily
available readily available yes yes
definitely yeah I think the one thing
I'm looking forward to the most are the
people man it's funny going back to the
whole oh man you know how people view
the population of LA like I can't hang
or I can't hang around people I can't I
can't stand the people in LA yeah and
I'll tell you man like you like you said
they just haven't found the right pocket
yet like I cannot wait
to hang out with the people in LA yeah
rich roll I mean who lives out like in
Malibu Canyon or dr. Christopher Ryan
yeah or around the Patrick you have all
of these these amazing people but then
you have much people who aren't
public-facing as well I have more
friends in Los Angeles than probably any
other city except from maybe Dayton but
even then it's probably pretty close
it's just cuz there's so many people
there's 20 million people in the Greater
Los Angeles area but it also doesn't
feel crazy packed like New York City
does to me when I go to New York I
totally get the appeal for some people
it is so overwhelming and
overstimulating to me that it plus the
weather is just like it's like Ohio if
I'm if I want that weather I'd much
rather live in Ohio and so I'm looking
forward to the weather I'm looking
forward to the opportunities I'm looking
forward to the people I'm looking
forward to creating meaningful video
work and podcasting and writing and and
building a new network of people so we
can try to help other people share
continue to share our recipe and other
recipes that illuminate the path yeah
we've got some questions here before we
dive into those Ryan just a quick note I
have my final writing workshop of the
year so this is October 22nd it's called
how to write better it's a two-hour live
workshop you also if you can't attend
the live session you'll have access to
the the recorded video afterward it's I
do these like once or twice I'm sorry
two or three times a year and this is my
last one this year I don't know when I'm
going to do it again it's an attenuated
version of my four-week writing class
which you can sign up for and at anytime
that one is automated you can find both
of those the the October 22nd 2-hour
workshop and the four-week class over at
how to write better org and that's
really for anyone who wants to improve
their writing I think the the rising
tide lifts all boats and so some people
who attend that class are I've had
medical doctors attended I've had high
school students attended and they're
looking to improve the writing some
people want to write the next great
novel or they want to write a memoir or
a nonfiction book or they just want to
improve their business emails or maybe
they just want to start blogging for the
first time and they're afraid to take
that leap I sort of go through the
fundamentals of how to improve your
writing and then also how to get it out
into the world and accept that criticism
that you're going to get from the
writing
but out there in the world it's called
how to write better how to write better
dot or the details you got anything else
for right here right now before we move
into these voicemails that we got right
no man let's dive into it all right this
first question is from Hannah in
Minneapolis I'm calling today because I
just first wanted to thank Josh and Ryan
for speaking so openly about their past
and their dysfunctional families
specifically Josh thinking about his dad
who has mental illness as someone who
grew up with a mentally ill dad also
schizophrenic and bipolar it's something
that I grew up with nobody talking about
and it was a very shameful and secretive
topic so getting older and hearing
people that I respect talking about
similar issues means a lot to me and I'm
sure it means a lot to other people so
along with that my question is two
questions I guess how do you move past
feelings of shame not necessarily you
know that topic specifically but just
around any past mistakes or you know
embarrassing parts of your history and
then as far as getting rid of stuff how
do you make sure that you're accepting
the past and moving on when getting rid
of stuff and not just trying to get rid
of something without actually dealing
with the emotional baggage of it say if
you had a breakup and you just get rid
of all the stuff that that person owned
to move on do you feel like that's truly
dealing with the issue do you feel like
somebody has to do more work or do you
think that getting rid of stuff kind of
helps you deal with that emotional
baggage and or shame I think I think
this question is important so so this is
in a way I mean this episodes about
relocating but but part of that means
leaving behind something right now and
so that that's why we had Shawn pull out
a couple voicemails here that we felt
were apropos for this topic and and
sometimes it's hard to move on whether
it's literally they physically move on
to a new place because you're so
attached
to the place that you're at Dayton was
that way for me where it was like I love
this place man it was hard to let go of
that but I also knew I wanted to to
expand and grow and the last couple
years I really felt like Missoula was
stifling me in that way like I didn't
wasn't growing as much as I was I wasn't
getting what I originally got from
Missoula and I wasn't able to give what
I could give accordingly because I
wasn't growing as much and so I find
that that shame is an interesting word
that she's using here yeah and I think
part of this has to do I saw I've talked
about this book recently but the book we
came out recently called black privilege
by by Charlemagne and who's like this
hip hop radio deejay guy but it's a
really good book but it's these eight
principles of living your own life
basically the the subtitle of the book
is opportunity comes to those who create
it yeah and that's kind of what we're
trying to do with Los Angeles is create
our own opportunity in a way as opposed
to waiting for someone to pick you and
and she she said that she's feeling
shame here I think one of the ways to
avoid the shame is to live your truth
yeah and and sometimes that starts with
something that you think should be
shameful shame has to do with how you
think other people perceive you quite
often right and and so maybe naming
something that would otherwise be
shameful
I was here's something I was a goodwill
yesterday and so I was donating that I
was using 9090 rule and there are some
things I hadn't used in the last 90 days
and probably wasn't going to use in the
next 90 day so there are a few shirts
and some other things and then there was
a sex swing that I hadn't used in the
last 90 day now I'm gonna be honest it
was a sex swing that I got that looked
kind of I was a little scared to use it
and so I never we never used it I
wouldn't donate a used sex swing to the
goodwill although I'm sure there at the
goodwill right now like what the hell is
this thing now I think most people would
probably be ashamed to mention that
right probably but it's the truth
right and yes I'm not gonna show you
pictures of me on a sex swing like
that's private it's personal right
and and but the truth is that I have sex
and I enjoy it and sometimes there are
COO Tremont's involved and that's okay
I'm not ashamed of that I'm proud of a
life that I live and my life is
congruent with the life I want to live
and so when we experience shame I think
quite often is because there's some in
congruence there there is this I think
other people think I'm supposed to live
this way and I'm not living this way and
thus I feel shame because of it but he
just live your truth that's one of the
principles from from that book then the
truth can't be used against you right
and man it's so freeing then for me to
be able to say that like how are you
gonna use it against me
so what right yeah I mean it you don't
have sex you don't want to have sex if
you're asexual okay that's fine I don't
care if you're asexual I personally am
NOT I enjoy having sex and so I'm okay
to talk about that yeah I think the best
way to yet to avoid the shame like you
said is to live your truth but like to
do that as much as possible yes because
like the more you practice like the less
you care what other people think yes I
mention something right now I go tell
someone that you're some spell something
you're ashamed of yeah and just talk it
out with them and sorry with a trusted
person like I don't I don't know the
people were listening to this for the
most part there's about a million people
listening to this podcast I don't know
most of you and so I wouldn't start with
just Helen telling complete strangers
although if you have some serious
courage that's one great way to do it
start with someone that you know you're
safe with like I know I could tell Ryan
anything right I could tell Ryan where I
hid the bodies right he would be like
okay listen and he knows on the same way
with him like he's not gonna judge me
I'm not gonna judge him having that a
person like that in your life is good
good you can test out some of these
things you could test out your truths on
that person and you know what Josh
there's someone out there who they would
look at you very shamefully for a having
owned a sex swing yeah well that tells
me more about them right
well yeah but you know I teach there oh
man like
it doesn't I don't want to say the
person who is you know looking at you
shamefully because you in a sex swing
that doesn't make him a bad person that
makes him judgmental and well judgment
is about a mirror that reflects
insecurities the person who's doing the
judges sure I guess what I'm getting at
though is you know we we have to choose
very deliberately who we bring into our
lives yes and that's someone who's not
going to bring into your life there are
going to be some really very much you
know religious people out there who
would look at having a you know a sex
swing is really shameful ok great
they're not gonna be part of your
community I'm not even gonna look back
at them and tell them that they're
insecure I'm not gonna look at them and
say you're judgmental I'm not gonna look
at them and say oh yeah well you know
really the screw you for judging me I'm
just gonna look at them and say oh I'm
sorry this isn't your flavor have a nice
day yeah and then I'm not gonna hang out
with that person in fact I'm gonna live
my truth 100% so I can have genuine
people in my life like I would never
have someone in my life that I felt like
I had to hide some sort of shameful
thing from like if you were gonna you
know judge me for being a you know a
drug addict for being you know an extra
addict then I'm not gonna look sorry
that that's not your flavor Josh but
like that's who I used to be right and I
have you know learned a lot of lesson
from that and this is who I am now but
like I know that you accept me so you're
gonna be part of my community there are
people out there who aren't gonna be
able to be part of your community but
the only would be how hard would be if
you had to live with the shame yeah
exactly exactly and so living with shame
is difficult it will weigh you down
figuratively but but it also might weigh
you down literally in the sense that it
prevents you from moving on yeah and and
so being a shame is is going to prevent
you from from moving that direction so
she actually mentioned something in the
voicemail she said she thanked me for
sharing my story about my dad who was
schizophrenic and bipolar and like she
said some about it being like courageous
or that it was a difficult thing to
share it wasn't difficult for me to
share because it's the truth it just is
what it is
and and and that's that's why it wasn't
difficult because I'm okay with speaking
the truth now
there have been times where I will
temporarily quash something and not talk
about it like we haven't talked about
moving from missoula to Los Angeles
because we won't we wanted to wait and
and surprise our audience with it
publicly but if this is like a cathartic
experience for me just being able to
talk about like you know what Missoula
was great it served its purpose but I
feel like I had grown beyond what
Missoula had to offer for me and I think
in a weird way I will I'll be able to
reconnect with Missoula because I'll be
coming back here occasionally and I'll
be able to appreciate it more from afar
as opposed to being steeped in the thing
that is no longer serving its purpose
for me and so I think part of moving on
is is yes of course letting go the shame
now she asked about the accept do I just
accept it with the physical things or
whatever and and do you just get like
something you're shameful of do you get
rid of all the physical memories so the
some thing that came to my mind was like
when I got divorced you know I didn't
it's a shame that no I I absolutely did
but I'll say though I felt I felt a lot
of shame the pictures of our like
wedding and stuff I got rid of them not
because I wanted to forget it but it was
because I wanted to move forward and I
didn't want to get stuck in that in that
shameful feeling but I'll tell you dude
getting rid of the pictures doesn't make
it not happen it doesn't make me forget
right you know we always say like the
memories are not in the things are
inside of us and guess what I still
remember a lot of a lot of things from
that marriage yeah and a lot of shame
that I felt from that marriage but you
didn't keep the triggers around to keep
feeling it either right exactly so you
know when it comes to those physical
possessions that Hannah was talking
about like if they're not adding value
like I'm sure there's something I still
have for my marriage yeah like in like
whether it's a spoon or a coffee mug I
mean I know that I came across something
the other day it was a like a
screwdriver or something like god I've
had this for like you know however long
my point is is that if it's adding value
to my life then I'm going to keep it I'm
not going to hold on to something just
to say oh well one day one day I'll face
those emotions and one day I'll work
through those if I'm not gonna use it
in the next 90 days if I haven't used it
in the last 90 days it doesn't matter
who shared that possession with me right
I'm just I'm not going to I'm not gonna
hold on to it I'm serving a purpose for
you anymore right exactly man so I mean
I think I guess what we're trying to
tell Hannah is don't look at your
material possessions as memories of
shame just look at them as just as what
they are physical possessions are they
are they adding value to your life now
if you've got something in your life
let's say it is a screwdriver I'm just
gonna go with that because I mentioned
it earlier and every time you use that
screwdriver it it brings up really sad
memories and you feel shame and it
brings up the past relationship bla bla
bla okay get rid of screwdriver because
at that point it's not adding value to
your life it's making you feel worse
right then it is making you feel better
or it's making you force it's not a tool
anymore yeah it's not so cool right
exactly
yeah and so she the last thing she asked
was about do I have ticks should I
accept it or she'll just move on I think
that's the same thing you have to accept
it before you can move on right you have
to accept what happened in the past
and I think the the biggest example of
this remember when a couple years ago
Charlie Sheen came out or having HIV
yeah and he can't win on the Today Show
I could tell that was probably one of
the most cathartic experiences of his
life because he had been hiding
something for so long and been paying
people off and and eventually got to
this point where he's like I can't do
this anymore
right and so living his truth all of a
sudden made it all go away no at least
the the the shame or the the anxiety
around trying to hide it right we try to
hide things and we start lying and in
lies about the lies to cover up all
their lies and yeah that is a terrible
cycle and you won't feel you won't feel
good about it at all and I'd love to
send you a copy of our book everything
that remains it's a memoir about letting
go of a whole lot of stuff over the
course of five years Ryan and I we we
were the suit-and-tie corporate guys
married guys with bad childhoods who
climbed the corporate ladder and then we
decided to to let all that go and become
minimalists and Shaun if you could send
her the book or the eBook version of
that
or you know it's on audiobook now it's
like a five and a half hour audiobook if
you have any audible download codes that
would be great she might enjoy the the
audiobook since she already listens to
the podcast our next question is from
Jagger in Phoenix my girlfriend and I
are game-planning for the next few years
of our lives and the humor to the
teacher and I work at the diet rep on
that hospital and then either are very
high paying jobs and we're both thinking
about trying to find a house others
off-grid but that probably is not going
to be the cheapest of options and we're
trying to figure out how exactly we can
make that work in the sense that of
putting down as large of a down payment
on the house as possible but we're not
in debt for very long
what potentially buying the house
outright now since we don't get paid a
lot we probably can't buy the house up
right so it feels like we're kind of
being forced in situation what we're
going to have to accept that we're going
to have to take on debt and one of the
big things that I know you guys preach
is that there is no such thing as good
debt so I need your guys's help and kind
of either justifying a buying house and
not taking on the debt if that's even
possible although I don't think it is or
trying to find some way to get around
the day yeah or just whatever I'm quite
frankly I'm just looking for guidance on
what what seems to be a very a difficult
issue for someone that wants to pursue a
minimalist lifestyle like myself and
like my girlfriend so Ryan I had to
think about this and I mean obviously
we're moving out to one of the more
expensive cities in the country and I
certainly couldn't afford to buy a house
in Los Angeles no when I say forward I
mean without going into debt that's what
I mean by Ford if you have to go into
debt you can't afford a thing and and
the one exception I would ever make in
my own personal life I'm not prescribing
this to anyone else
the one exception I would make on my own
life is if I had 50% to put down so if
to use Dayton Ohio as an example if I
wanted a $200,000 house it should be a
really nice house in Dayton Ohio right
my friend Annie lives in one of the
nicest neighborhoods in Dayton and her
house is less than $200,000 and it's you
you sit that house in Missoula and be
$600,000 it's great and Los Angeles to
certainly be over a million dollars so
to say a $200,000 house I'd have to be
able to put at least half down $100,000
so I'd have to save up that money and
then for me I personally wouldn't do
more than a 7 year fixed rate mortgage
so then the question becomes can I for
what the payments are for those 7 years
and ideally I'd love to pay it off
quicker than 7 if possible so any extra
money I had because I want to get rid of
that debt altogether I no longer want
the debt in my life that gives me the
same flexibility to be mobile right
because even if you own the house and
you have no debt on it you could let it
sit there if you couldn't sell it you
could do you you wouldn't be tied to
that mortgage payment still and so
jagara I don't want you to be tied to a
mortgage payment unless you absolutely
have to be I could understand
circumstances where if you put 20% down
and do up to a 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage I certainly wouldn't go
anywhere beyond that and that that would
be the outer limit being able to do 20%
now he said something interesting Ryan
he said he said I can't buy it outright
and my my response would be
you can't buy it outright yet I mean it
may be part of it is saving up enough
money so you can buy it outright or pay
at least half of it outright eventually
well the one thing that stood out to me
during that whole voicemail is he said
he probably can't buy it outright and
there was a lot of probably's and maybes
and I don't knows which led him to his
final you know question thereof you know
is it okay for me to just accept the
fact that we're gonna have to take on a
mortgage yeah but dude you haven't even
looked into how much a house off the
grid is gonna cost right guarantee I've
actually been looking into this okay I
could do it for 60 thousand bucks uh-huh
like if I if I had the piece of land
sixty thousand dollars I could build a
simple home
with solar solar panels and do some
off-the-grid stuff yeah so I've stayed
in a few of those from Airbnb I've
talked to architects who design them and
and it's usually under $100,000 every
time yeah I mean yeah for the for the
cost of the home I mean that the land is
gonna be a little bit different I
actually could do it for less than sixty
thousand bucks I was talking to um our
buddy uh Derek who has that he's got the
show on TLC or something I don't watch
cable TV anymore but he goes around he
builds tiny houses right and I was
talking to him about designing an
off-the-grid tiny house and I was like
yeah I'm trying to save up like you know
forty fifty maybe sixty thousand bucks
and he was like dude he's like we can do
that for way less than sixty thousand
bucks
Wow so so my point is Jagger is dude
you've got to come up with a plan of and
you know what that for me we're what
started as your budget man like what are
you budgeting for so figure out where
every single bit of your money is going
with you and your partner every single
month then figure out how much it's
going to cost to get that off-the-grid
house and how much are you going to have
to save into Josh's point yeah you're
right right now you can't do it but you
certainly could be able to do in the
future with the right plan I mean I hate
to use the cliche of like you know plan
your work and work your plan but Jagger
this is what you got to do if that's
what you truly truly want you've got to
find out some more information you got
to come up with a better plan and you
have to work that plan and if it takes
you five years great if he takes you ten
years great yeah I mean when it comes to
you know going all-in with a 30-year
mortgage dude I don't know when I would
ever do that I mean no I'm not I'm not
like knocking anyone who has done that
you know like you said that I'm not
prescribing this to anyone I've done it
in the past yeah but I know like the
condo I got and Dayton and this is
anecdotal man is my only experience with
owning a home but you know I paid you
know however much I paid for it and then
five years later I lost five figures man
I lost five figures on that house so I
was completely upside-down after five
years in the end what do they say the
average um I'm not ready to return but
like your average you're gonna get your
investment back after five years yeah so
you wouldn't want a person
unless you know you're gonna be
somewhere for at least five you right so
you could say you could make the money
back on that house there are awesome
success stories out there I've got you
know mentoring mentees who all the time
will say oh yeah I don't know what to do
you know I've got a house right now and
it's probably equity but probably has
you know an extra forty or fifty
thousand bucks in it great like that's
also possible
yeah for sure um but but Jagger I guess
my biggest piece of advice to you is you
got to find out more information and
you've got to come up with a plan I
think that's important and that
translates to exactly what we're doing
right now it's not like we decided to
willy-nilly up and move to Los Angeles
no it was about a plan it's like to you
just like been in the works for two
years yeah and and and can I can I
afford this what are the opportunities
and and what makes sense for my
circumstances and for our entire team i
what and and you don't take that lightly
but then also there's this other you
know I did a little bit of a teaser on
Facebook last week and said hey we're
moving what questions do you have for us
and why answer some of those in a minute
Facebook and Twitter and one of the
person just said why like why are you
moving and I can give you a bunch of
good reasons about community and access
and all these other things but part of
it has to do with with the feeling that
you experience it should you there's
this gut feeling and I heard Sam Harris
talk about it recently about having more
brain cells and your gut then most
mammals have in their brains and there's
a I can't go into the science behind it
without without a sounding woowoo and if
anyone else would say that besides Sam
Harris I would think it was whoo-whoo as
hell but it has to do that with he had
this self-defense podcast that that I
think you you may have listened to it I
don't know no yeah no your Matt Devo was
recommending California yeah so anyway
he was talking about like these gut
instincts that we get and especially
women get when they you know their get
into an elevator with a large man and
it's like in our society it's impolite
to get off that elevator but like no
other time in the world would you get
into a enclosed box with a predator
right right and and that's you get that
gut feeling act on that gut feeling it's
a part of that through the gut feeling
but then can
you have a plan to back up that guy
feeling don't just jump into the thing
but fall they got feeling into a certain
extent and then and then make sure you
you plan accordingly on top of it
oh by the way Jagger we would love to
give you a couple tickets to our Phoenix
event we're we're doing this 40 City
tour this year it's called the less is
now tour we're gonna be in Phoenix our
special guests there will be Joshua
Becker so Sean I think you reach out to
him maybe get him a couple tickets for
that event if if he's interested all
right she'll we'd love to hear what you
have to say so if you have a comment or
tip about relocating or or Los Angeles
or Missoula or Dayton or any advice for
any of the callers today as well you can
leave us a voicemail for zero six two
one nine seven eight three nine you can
also email a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists comm where our favorite
comments and tips on a future episode
okay before we dive into the lightning
round Ryan let's talk about some of our
upcoming tour stops never never in my
life Ryan that I think we'd ever have to
deal with scalpers if I would've went to
you seven years ago said Ryan seven
years now people gonna be scalping our
tickets are you serious yeah so there's
quite a few of our events have already
sold out most of the first-leg sold out
but then yes there are some cities that
are already sold out now and we're
getting ready to announce the Australia
Wave of the tour that would be twenty
early 2018 March 2018 so make sure
you're on our email list over at the
minimalists com also if you're on our
email list at the minimalists com you'll
get all of our new essays and stuff I
just wrote an essay about this tour
about traveling Ryan it's called
developing ears for travel and I like to
read that real quick and it's a good
jump off point to talk about some of
these tour stops we're going on it goes
a little something like this there are
three things I hate large crowds public
speaking and extensive travel and yet I
find myself on tour once again in fact
this year's lessons now tour is our
eighth tour in the seven years since
Ryan and I started the minimalists comm
from Seattle to San Diego Pittsburgh to
Portland Vermont to Vancouver we're
traveling to 40 cities this year to talk
about living a meaningful life with less
there comes a time when
we're on the road that I began to ask
myself why in the hell am I doing this
again which I should probably ask myself
before embarking on another multi month
of John around North America but the
initial excitement of planning coupled
with the perceived glamour of
exploration always seems to erase the
question at least for a while at some
point though often while parked at a
rest stop surrounded by a sea of
Midwestern cornfields that question and
interrupts my waning excitement and I
begin to wonder what I've gotten myself
into
that's the self-doubt that creeps in
another crowd this evening
two more hours of talking tonight 300
miles until our next city
yikes it's not that I actually hate
people speaking or travel rather these
things make me uncomfortable
so my answer to my internal why am i
doing this dialogue is simple I go on
tour not only to share our message of
simple and intentional living but also
to embrace my own discomfort in the
modern Western world once our basic
needs are met we have the means to
cocoon ourselves and perpetual comfort
by air conditioning technology and
consumer goods we ease into a daily life
that is rich in luxurious niceties but
lacks the rigor required for sustained
growth and without growth our lives lack
meaning purpose and passion it's no
wonder most people feel discontented
today we are vessels of anxiety stress
and debt camouflaged by consumerism so
despite my innate desire to stay home
and bubble wrap my life I hit the road
interact with other human beings and
face the terror of public speaking in
every city we visit each night we meet
people from various walks of life from
factory workers to executives high
school dropouts to college professors
monks to hoarders literally we had monks
and hoarders at the same event whether
they're young
old rich or poor black or white they all
ask the same fundamental questions how
do I live a meaningful life what must I
do to regain control who is the person I
want to become sure these questions
manifest differently depending on the
individual but one thing that has been
made clear to me over the past 7 years
is we're all different yet we're all the
same we all struggle we all fail and we
all desire to be the best version of
ourselves warts and all Ryan and I stand
on stage and present an in-depth talk at
each event but the real reason we host
these events is to listen it would be
easy comfortable even for us to stay
home and discuss simple living and our
books blog and podcast it's much more
difficult however to actively listen
real listening requires letting go of
expectations preconceptions and the
desire to be the center of attention
it's uncomfortable to do so but it's
necessary if we want to grow because if
we don't listen to the world around us
it's impossible to hear what's going on
inside us that's why travel is important
to me it forces me to confront
discomfort and develop ears to hear and
ultimately attempt to understand other
perspectives in time those perspectives
better shape our own worldview and Ryan
I think that's important here because
we're moving because it helps better
shape our worldview it'd be easy for me
to stay in Dayton Ohio and and just hang
out and write and maybe I'll do that one
day maybe I ought to sit back and
bloviate on the blog about simple living
from my ivory tower but right now I want
to continue to grow and embrace that
discomfort and it's difficult man yeah
especially difficult with me and my
health issues but it's it's really worth
it it's what makes life more meaningful
yeah you know as long as I still have
the energy to do all this men like I
absolutely am them all for it
so if you if you want to come out and
see us on tour we'll be in Canada by the
time this comes out we have already been
in Toronto Ottawa
drill looks like Vancouver's already
sold out Calgary is sold out
Edmonton looks like there's a few
tickets left by the time this comes out
you I'm not sure head on over to les is
now calm and you can find all the
tickets cities dates after that we're
doing three stops in New York City we'll
also be in Philadelphia a Salt Lake City
Denver Phoenix and we're going hometown
Dayton Ohio free event in Dayton Ohio
details of that are on that page as well
and we're going to be in Austin Texas
man it looks like that event is sold out
Dallas only a few tickets left in Dallas
and then Houston man what look what's
going on Houston lately yeah did I yeah
I hope we can still have an event there
I mean I'm but yeah I don't know man I
know that there are like hotels that you
know have signs like we're still open
right all right um but yeah it's it's a
it's a couple months away yeah I'd love
to work where there's a there's a
nonprofit called Global living
I think it's global living let me let me
look it up real quick actually we'll
we'll find a link to in the show notes
they're helping they're helping a lot of
the rescue efforts they're all on the
ground and so I know a lot of people
donate to the Red Cross and they can be
very helpful but if you want to make
sure your money goes directly to to this
tragedy to help the people who are
surviving this I know nine people
already died so far it's nothing like
Katrina numbers because it's not a wall
of water that is hitting an entire city
that's below sea level it's still a lot
of water you see the pictures of this
thing and lievable it's it is truly
unbelievable as all those so let's see
if we can we can donate a large chunk of
the profits if not all of them from that
Houston event to help these these
survivors out yeah definitely ma'am
let's let's take a look at let me I've
got it right here it's the global it's
called global giving and they are vetted
by a Charity Navigator which ranks
different charities they've also been
recommended by the Houston Chronicle and
by NPR and so we can give we'll put a
link in the show notes if you want to
help some of the folks out in Houston
that's one way to do it you can give to
them directly and then
we can give profits from our Houston
event yeah man and I'm gonna put you on
the spot but like what do you think
about doing the thing with the iTunes or
is it what Apple podcasts or whatever
thing now yeah whatever it is man that
we did for the malaria foundation okay
so let's say alright so if you're
someone out there if you're cool doing
this yeah if you're someone out there
who doesn't have ten bucks to give to
this organization just leave us leave us
a review if it's a one-star review
we'll still donate ten bucks to help the
victims there in Houston hopefully it's
a five-star review and you really get a
lot of value out of this podcast but but
yeah man I mean as much as we can do to
help okay so it looks like for it so
let's do that so this will be out
September 5th this episode comes out
sweet let's say the entire month of
September entire month of September
Kurt we currently have thirty three
hundred and fifty two reviews on Apple
podcasts okay so for every review that
we get ideally we prefer five stars that
really helps us out yes but if you hate
us what we want to be an honest review
yeah yeah yeah it does it should be
honest we're not asking for fluff here
no no no we're not paying you for
reviews and so if you want to leave us
one-star my first question is if you
hate listening to us that much you can
do this one star you probably listen
this long but you know what maybe you're
hate listening to us and there's a whole
thing about like they did the study on
howard stern's listeners like the people
who really loved him listen for an hour
a day that people would hate him listen
for two hours a day and so does love to
get themselves around up and say yeah
the runny relational outrage and and so
yeah well we'll donate $10 to
GlobalGiving
for every Apple podcast review that we
get during the month of September eleven
seventeen and that will go a hundred
percent of that money it looks like goes
to help the in fact let me I've got this
link here Ryan I can read a little bit
about the the global giving initiative
this is for the hurricane Harvey Relief
Fund they're trying to raise two million
dollars and so we can certainly help out
with that here's what it says Ryan in
the summary hurricane Harvey has caused
widespread catastrophic flooding and
damage in Texas and along the Gulf Coast
this fund will provide relief to
survivors in the
form of emergency plies supplies like
food water and medicine in addition
here's the important part yeah in
addition to long-term recovery
assistance to help residents recover and
rebuild awesome all donations to this
fund will exclusively support relief and
recovery efforts from this storm so it's
not going to go somewhere else in an
organization let's see if we can help
them out let's donate the money from our
Houston event any other profits there
and then 10 bucks for every review that
we get on Apple podcast slash iTunes
whatever you want to call it you just go
over to iTunes comm slash the
minimalists or you can go to our website
and even if you use it like I use a
different podcast player you can still
go over to Apple podcast and leave a
rating you just have to log in even if
you have an Android phone you can you
can download Apple podcasts and and
leave a rating there that also helps our
simple of a message reach more people
that's why why we're doing it it's not
completely altruistic but we do wanna
help some people out along the way so
we'll donate our money and if you want
to donate as well we'll put a link to
that in the show notes continuing on to
the tour stuff Ryan after Texas will be
we got Dallas we got Houston and Austin
Austin's already sold out only a few
tickets left in Dallas and then we're
gonna be in Nashville Washington DC
atlanta only a few tickets left in
Atlanta Tampa we just found a huge
theater in Tampa so that thing sold out
Denver sold out as well we got a bigger
theater in Denver nice we got a bigger
theater in Tampa so both of those sold
out but we have bigger space now so
there are if you went there and it was
sold out there are now tickets available
in Tampa and Denver and then we're
finishing the year Detroit Milwaukee and
if you're in Australia stay tuned make
sure you're on our email list we're
gonna be announcing that really soon
we're headed over to see your records
Australia and and New Zealand we hope to
have those dates within within the next
few weeks ideally so though you'll be
the first to know if you're on our email
list actually you'll be the second note
though our patreon supporters will be
the first to know we always announce the
new stuff with our our patreon
supporters first all right Ryan we
talked about Houston let's move on to
some light name yeah man you know what
time it is it is time for our hashtag
ask the minimalists lightning round yes
indeed this where we answer questions
from from social media we're on facebook
and instagram and twitter at
minimalists during the lightning round
this will Ryan and I both do our best to
answer each question which is a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pit the answers
on social media if you'd like you can
also now find all of our our pithy
quotes in one place thanks to our friend
Jessica Williams and folks are respire
media they created this awesome website
called minimal Maxim's comm and every
time you refresh it pops up a new quote
of ours that you can tweet and share and
there are hundreds of them cataloged
over there at minimal Maxim's com
awesome alright our first question is
from Catherine is it cheaper to sell
furniture before the move and buy new or
to pay to have it all moved I mean so
I'll give a short answer then I have a
lot to expand on here my short written
answer that is tweetable is neither
cheap nor expensive or synonyms for
better and so I just want to keep that
in mind so I've done both when we moved
out to Montana I got rid of everything
everything I had fit in my car
you know we rented that cabin that was
already furnished I'm doing furnishing
air quotes there was a couch and a table
and a bed two beds and and that was
about it and that was great for us like
we didn't yeah it worked out really well
and so that that really worked out
because I didn't want to rent a u-haul
and try try to store the stuff and I
wasn't really sure where we were going
from there and I already didn't own a
lot of stuff anyway
but then for this move we're kind of
doing both we got on Craigslist
yesterday and sold two desks we're
giving away the dining room table to our
good friends Nate and Rochelle because
they're moving into a new house this
month actually and so it was perfect
timing otherwise I would have sold the
stuff sold on Craigslist in an hour
that's awesome in an hour and it was
just like a simple like standing desks
it was and you know he made a few
hundred bucks off of the stuff we we
sold on Craigslist and that was really
helpful there are other things we're
moving Beck's is doing it while we're on
tour in Canada Beck's is going to be
driving a
u-haul trailer to LA for us so or you
can hire movers and do that and it's
really up to you what you decide you
want to take here's the thing to keep in
mind the things that you purchased for
your current space may not work in a new
space and so you have to plan
accordingly I wouldn't I wouldn't try to
hold on to something and cram it into a
space I'm gonna try to cram your old
life into a new space ooh that's my
there we go that's my tweetable answer
that's it give me a second a second
minimal maximum there Shawn don't try to
cram your old life into your new space
and I think if we if we look at it that
way
then we will bring things forward but
there'll be other things we may have to
reacquire or the thing I'm gonna do is
experiment this first I'm going to try
an experiment in radical simplicity when
we first move out there I'm gonna have
very little I always have to have a bed
and and a few other things and your
consumables and paper towels and and and
toilet paper but I'm not gonna I'm gonna
see how long over this two-month period
because it's a two-month trial period
I'm gonna kind of deprive myself for
those two months to see okay what am I
really missing and what I really need so
we end up staying in the house that
we're renting then we can bring those
things in very slowly and deliberately
as opposed to well I'm supposed to have
here is the 19 things that everyone has
in their home so you should own them too
to be a good minimalist you have to own
these 43 items no it doesn't work like
that you can get by without yeah
absolutely
my short answer would be don't ask what
the cheaper option is ask what the
opportunity cost is there's always going
to be a cheaper option so what you know
this question it's like what's the
cheapest you know what like you said man
cheap doesn't always mean better yeah
and for me it's not about us something
as cheaper if it's more expensive is
what what is that opportunity costs and
I'm missing out on that's a that we
don't think about that cost because it's
not the price tag right right
maybe it's the the the the cheap here's
another pithy one for you Sean the the
cheap sometimes cheap is too expensive
yeah yeah that's true
absolutely so an opportunity cost I mean
I'm sure most people know what that is
but it's basically an economic term
where you look at the next you look at
what you're giving up essentially the
next best thing that you're giving up so
in
in in Katherine's situation if she is
going to sell her furniture let's say
it's like a beautiful couch that she
really likes
she sells that she moves to her new
place she buys a couch for what you know
what she sold it for so there's a net
zero cost there but if the couch isn't
as beautiful as the one that she had
then that's the opportunity cost she's
missing out on having something that she
truly truly loves in her home so that's
the question isn't how cheaper expensive
something is it's what is the
opportunity cost oh yeah totally agree
man and that opportunity costs needs to
be weighed in what are the what is the
actual cost of of the thing it's gonna
go beyond just the price tag yeah
alright our next question is from Sarah
I want to move so bad but cannot decide
is it better to stick with what I have
or go somewhere new and start completely
over how did you decide it was time to
move well here's my short answer then I
can expand on her question it's best to
choose to graduate from a place before
you're ready to divorce it and I'm
somewhere in between right now I feel
like I graduated from his Oh two years
ago and now I'm the townie who was like
hanging out and just you know what was
the movie Bert Kreischer Van Wilder was
that it Bert Kreischer was in Van Wilder
the movies based on his life oh I didn't
had no idea yeah that is hilarious
and um anyway yes Ryan Ryan Reynolds
plays basically the who Bert Kreischer
well he just stuck around College for a
really long time that's so funny and I
kind of feel that like with Mizzou like
I feel like I graduated from it a couple
years ago and I felt really good about
this place and moving on from it and now
I'm at a point where I'm like this
relationship isn't going as well for me
like it's leading toward divorce let's
let's let's leave before the divorce
comes about and so yeah you you want to
graduate before you divorce it but but
how did you know it was time to move
something you just know for me you just
know and I can give you the stats and
then and here are the opportunities I'm
going toward but if I didn't have that
feeling if I didn't feel good about it
it it would be moot
feelings a feeling oh that feeling of a
feeling I'm I'm employing my feelings my
short answer is when relocating it's
important to know what you're running
toward running from something can lead
to the same or bigger problems so when I
think about moving from missoula to LA
like if I'm running from anything it
would be like this feeling of stagnation
this feeling of being too settled being
too comfortable right which sounds like
a really weird being too comfortable
that's out of those three descriptors
that I just used man-like running away
from being comfortable is probably the
number one thing which sounds weird
running away from being I say that was
reading like it's like comfort like true
comforts are bubble wrapping your life
and removing all the sharp edges from
life right and yeah so I mean if
anything I'm running away from that but
you know what I'm running towards in LA
to me means so much more than what I am
leaving here in Missoula and I think you
know and I I don't think I know there
are people out there who they feel like
moving to a new city I have friends and
family who have done this or are doing
it now and at the end of the day running
from a problem or running from an old
life to to start a new life somewhere
else if you don't know that new life
you're running towards then you just can
again create the same or even bigger
problems in that new space so Sarah get
clear on what you're running towards get
clear on what you're running away from
but either way like yes make it a very
deliberate decision yeah and don't just
run away as what you're saying it's okay
to run in the other direction make sure
you know where you're going for me I'm
running toward the weather I'm running
toward the opportunity I'm running
toward the community I'm running toward
the beauty I'm running toward up the
access to the things that I want access
to I'm not running away from this place
and it was important Beck's and I had
several conversations about it like I
want to make sure I'm not just running
away from this and and and the grass is
greener on the side kind of thing the
thing about that is sometimes the grass
is greener and you have to you have to
determine if it is greener then
maybe you do want to run toward that or
first maybe try to fix the grass that's
in the that's in your own yard
and and then if you can't do that then
then you go ahead and you move forward
but I think I think ultimately you just
know we've got like four or five other
questions here that we're gonna do an
overtime episode so we'll continue this
relocation discussion over on patreon
some really good questions here bunch of
people are asking questions social media
so just a few um here continuity of care
seems like a big deal these days because
it ties in with most people's health
insurance or lack thereof how do you
find a reputable doctor dentist pharmacy
etc this is something that scares me
when I think about moving someone else
Jonathan said what is the one thing you
believe is the hardest to find once you
move to a new city I'm not talking about
an item but what's the hardest thing to
find it in the community Natasha said
what were the criteria to decide which
city to move to what we can already
talked about that and then she said how
do you choose your new houses so we'll
be able to talk about that and a handful
of other questions here as well what
will you miss most about Montana did you
have a pre pre move yard sale how long
did it take for you to pack up your
stuff so we'll talk about all of that in
the overtime episode over on patreon but
first it is time for our added value
portion of the shows where we each
recommend something we talk about
something that has added value to our
lives recently before that though if you
find value in the minimalist podcast
would you consider becoming a supporter
of the show even though this is one of
the largest podcasts in the world that
is a weird thing to say Ryan I have it
here written in front of me I still
don't believe you I I think you're just
making that up then then Apple podcast
has been really kind to us and and
ranked us quite a bit so it is one of
the largest podcasts in the world it's
frequently in the top hundred it's been
in the top ten before it's top three in
Australia over 400 days on the charts in
Australia 200 days the United States of
the top 100 and the listenership
continues to grow even with all the new
podcasts I'm saying all that not to
impress you but to impress upon you our
desire for your help so basically it is
one
largest podcast in the world but we
don't take any money from advertisers
because advertisements most of them at
least they suck can you imagine if we
had to start shilling for some underwear
or some mattress company No
and it just wouldn't it wouldn't feel it
wouldn't feel good to me I don't think
we'd feel good about it plus being ad
free allows us to record this added
value segment each week without any bias
toward a sponsor which means that we can
recommend something because we truly get
value from it not because someone is
lining our pockets to talk about their
product so if you want to help keep the
podcast 100% advertisement free then
head on over to the minimalists comm and
click on the donate button over there at
the top from there you can contribute
one time via PayPal or on a per episode
basis via patreon as a reward for your
continued support our patreon supporters
get exclusive access to the minimalists
private podcast and monthly live streams
and occasional other bonuses so we do a
live stream each month and we also we're
recording these little private podcasts
where we'll do we'll expand on some of
the topics then we also have direct
communication with all of our patreon
supporters if you see us commenting in
the comments with folks interacting with
folks that is us interacting with you
it's the best place to interact with us
we also send out private emails to folks
before you know if tickets are available
you get advance access to certain events
and we also send out other little
reminders to all of our patreon
supporters we get about a million
downloads each month and we are not meet
month each episode really yeah yeah so
oh my gosh sorry I'm all nervous
obviously well on and that's why we can
talk about more stuff on patreon because
it's like a thousand people who support
us over there so we get about a million
downloads per episode and we're looking
for just one percent of our audience to
help support the show financially it's
worth noting that none of the money
contributed to this podcast goes to Ryan
or to me to rectly instead we're using
this money to build the podcast and film
studio that we mentioned earlier which
will allow us to take live callers on
the air improve overall audio quality
and produce different types of podcast
episodes shorter episodes longer
episodes and experimental episodes and
the film studio will also allow us to
make a video version of the
Podcast as well as other meaningful
films like webseries and TV shows TV or
video interviews many documentaries
video Q&A s live specials video essays
vlogs live streams and much more so are
you willing to be part of the 1% of
listeners who helped us create something
meaningful
if so visit the minimalists comm and
click donate if you're already a
supporter thank you your support is
adding value to my life it's adding
value to Ryan's life and it's adding
value to many other lives and for that
we are grateful ok Ryan what does added
value to your life recently well dude
Andrew Belle's dive deep just came out
that is phenomenal album it's so good
man the more I listen to it the more I
like it and it's funny because I can't
tell you how many times a new album
comes out and I'm like yeah this isn't
as good as the last album I know but
then I'll listen to it like 2 or 3 times
I'm like [ __ ] this is good so like yeah
definitely go check that out amount and
then do with this smoke that's been in
Missoula I have the I bought air
purifiers I'm sorry I bought an air
purifier yeah like two years ago when
the smoke like I got through that level
2015 I never got to before we're late I
mean it looked like you know Beijing
like everyone's walking around in the
masks and like yeah it was I mean
basically they were saying hey don't go
outside the air quality is really bad if
you do go outside wear a mask because
it's so unhealthy for you and I'll tell
you man with that air purifier like dude
I can't I can't smell the smoke in my
house as soon as I step outside my house
like it smells like someone's can't you
know has a campfire going or something
yeah but um I'll tell you even even if
like I'm gonna bring these LA with me I
have to now actually
oh my bought one at the at the beginning
of this fire season because I noticed
takeno smoke arises so I put one up in
my room anyway I'm gonna bring to LA
with me I'll just say in general man
like I really like and I just noticed
the air quality difference man I know
it's weird but I don't have enough or a
couple years man like I can totally
notice it so my doctor recently told me
about a study that came out
and I was totally shocked by the the
most effective hepa air air filter
machine yeah you're not gonna believe it
man I didn't believe it either at first
until I started doing it
it's a box fan with an air conditioner
filter taped to the back of it
really yeah I'm bringing to Los Angeles
with me it's better than like the
whirlpool yeah it's the as a scientist
from Caltech or Stanford one of the two
that's awesome
did this this I mean it they look
they're not aesthetically pleasing it's
a box fan yeah but if you're if you're
just trying to deal with smoke for a
temporary period of time and that's
gonna be wait like this world this
whirlpool air filters like 200 bucks
yeah I mean I hate recommending
something I wouldn't I wouldn't
recommend it if I didn't feel like it
made a huge difference but here's what
I'll say though if you want something
that's temporary use the box fan thing
it you're gonna get this roughly the
same same thing from the Whirlpool thing
if you want something more aesthetically
pleasing and you can afford it that's
gonna look a lot better in your home
long term having that that but the Box
fan works better than the whirlpool it's
gonna work slightly better well and the
point is that they work relatively the
same right
and if you just need something for a
temporary period do the Box fan we
borrowed one from the neighbor and then
went to Ace Hardware and bought a filter
he's buy a HEPA air conditioner filters
yeah regular and it covers the fan yep
it covers the fan perfectly you tape it
to it and it's good to go together
that's awesome it's it's been great it's
helped out there the air quality OLED
you know there's like a awesome
substitute for yeah yeah but if you want
one that's that's looks good
the Whirlpool one is great for sure all
right what is added value to my life you
talked about running away from a place
to running to a place or whatever
there's a show right now that is on
Netflix called Ozark have you heard of
it no Jason Bateman's in it it is so
good I'm only eight episodes in I won't
give any spoilers but there's one line
in there where they move to the Ozarks
and there's like which is like Missouri
Arkansas area right there on the
Missouri side and there's it's all this
water and people get around by boats and
it's like a weird vacation destination
for mid the Midwest
and there's a line in there where
everyone who comes here is running from
something
and yeah just if you are considering
relocating or taking a new job or
whatever don't just run from the thing
that you're at run towards somewhere the
show is amazing
it is amazing one of the best shows I've
seen a long time Ozark I'm music here's
a tech recommendation I used something
in my inbox you know about called
boomerang yeah so I can boomerang
messages to come back to me later they
just added a new feature it's a so this
is for Gmail it's called boomerang for
Gmail this other feature they added is
called Paul inbox pause so I can pause
my inbox and so no new messages come in
so I can just work from what I want and
this is really important to me because
sometimes I want to go into my inbox and
if there's any emails in there I start
addressing them right away yeah
well if it's paused and there's new new
emails in there I can go in there I can
start sending emails without getting
that barrage of all these new emails
that are coming in and so that's
something that has added value to my
life recently it's just part of the
normal boomerang thing and let's see I
already talked about tour dates so I
think that's all I got right now let's
move on to our next segments called
weight lifting with the minimalists a
new segment where we turn to our patreon
supporters into social media as well and
we ask what physical item is weighing
you down recently and why and then we we
help lift the weight this was an idea
from our friend Malcolm Fon ta we're
working together with him on this bag
it's a first physical product we've ever
we've ever put our name behind and yeah
we thought about you know physical items
weigh you down especially a bag right
but this bag I've gotten more value from
than anything else by the way you can I
wrote an essay called to keep travel
simple you can find it over at packed
bags calm phk tea bags calm and we
talked about the whole reason we decided
to finally do a physical product that
made sense to us but anyway he wanted to
talk about he wanted us to talk more
about the things that weigh people down
the physical items and so I reached out
this morning and had some people make
some suggestions alright so Jason asks a
question Ryan he bought he says what's
weighing him down his way
way way too much camping gear well dude
go camping or get rid of the gear man
yeah or or both right go camping with
his little gear as possible - just for a
night to see what what do you miss what
do you really need and what is just a
accoutrement that is perceived value
imaginary value I went on a seven-day
hike through Smoky Mountains in
Tennessee and I bought a sleeping bag
and a bag like I had to I had to have
both of those things to go on this trip
I ended up returning the bag and
borrowing this someone else's but I had
this sleeping bag in fact I hadn't when
we moved out to Montana because it was
shortly after that trip and then we
moved out there um I was like I'm not
gonna go camping ever again like this
isn't and if I do I will I will go like
I did last time borrow everything
everything that I can right it's not
something I'm gonna do on a regular
basis so I got rid of the sleeping bag
but yeah man it's like if you're gonna
if you're gonna go camping a lot then
dude you keep hold on to your camping
gear but if it's something that you're
doing once every year once every two
years there's probably a better way for
you to have access to the gear you need
without hanging on to a bunch of stuff
that's weighing you down if you feeling
weighed down dude that's a clear sign
that something's got to give now my
family owns camping gear and when I say
my family I mean Bexon Ella and they go
camp camping I I don't go camping with
them it's just not my thing I don't
enjoy camping I grew up poor we were to
get the electricity turned off sometimes
that was camping that's that's what I
imagine camping is like I've gone before
I've gone camping I don't want to put
myself into that again I will in fact
when they go camping in Montana I'll
often go up and spend the entire day
with him we'll go out on the lake and
and paddleboard and get on boats and
inner tubes and stuff and then when it
comes time to go to sleep I will drive
back to Missoula and get into my bed and
and and so that's what I prefer
but the camping gear as a men's value in
fact when Beck's is moving all of our
stuff out of Los Angeles she's gonna
take the long way she's gonna go down
the Oregon coast and she's gonna go
camping the the entire time that the
she's moving the stuff she's not gonna
stay in hotels or whatever cuz she
enjoys doing that she loves to go
camping and good for her she uses the
stuff all the time if it was just me in
the house having the camping gear would
be utterly useless and so figure out
what the things that you do use what are
the things that add imaginary value and
then let go of those things keep the
things that are essential for what you
want to do which is camp
what augments the camping experience
what gets in the way what is just fluff
we got a bunch of other weightlifting
with the minimalist questions here we'll
answer those in the overtime episode on
patreon as well we have I think half a
dozen episodes by now by the time this
comes out of bonus episodes a bunch of
live streams you'll have access to all
of that if you are a patreon supporter
you can also get it in your feed now too
so like I use overcast Ryan and I or
maybe use Apple podcasts or some other
podcast app the bonus that we call them
the minimalists private podcast you can
get them right there in that same Apple
podcast app but it shows up as a
separate feed so we've already done half
a dozen episodes that is going to
continue to grow as we keep doing these
these bonus episodes all right let's see
do we have anything else Ryan no man all
I got here are some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners hi this is
Casey from Denver and I wanted to touch
on someone's question from a couple tour
stops ago who had mentioned that she had
lost her father about two weeks prior to
the Meetup and I wanted to share
something that has worked for me so I am
29 and I have actually lost both of my
parents and I lost my dad more recently
about two years ago and after going
through this minimalism journey I
realized that a lot of the reason why I
held on to so many things after his
passing and especially with my mom's
passing as well was that was afraid that
I was going to lose them
so I actually only have one small item
from each of them and then on top of
that to remember more of my dad since
it's much more recent I have created a
playlist of some music that we shared
some of the music that he liked we do
not share common interests Oh Barbra
Streisand sorry about that
but when I'm doing something that
reminds me
such as cooking I like to put on that
playlist so I like to listen to a lot of
Simon and Garfunkel and what I can say
is that it never gets easy and it's
something that you'll they'll always
kind of be some type of dull pain but it
makes it a lot easier and the music
actually triggers a lot of those
positive memories that I had with my dad
so I hope that helps hi Josh and Ryan my
name is Boris 923 years old I'm from
London Ontario Canada and I've watched
your film and had been listening your
podcast religiously for the past three
months your message has really connected
with me and has opened my eyes to a more
attentional way of living both
physically and mentally this is my
brother announcing that 95% of my career
positions in my bedroom which is awesome
I have donated and sold about 40% of my
material things that no longer bring me
value I'm still evaluating every day the
things I have whether they bring value
or to donate hi Sheldon
all this making my move to Toronto the
summer and easier process in a way it
feels like a fresh start to me last
night
at around 12 a.m. I was woken abruptly
by a fire wall and banging on my door
I open my door and my brother informing
we had to evacuate the building I
quickly threw out some clothes grab my
phone it was all my way of the building
as a suicide watching fire trucks
arrived one after the other and the
numerous people exiting the building
with the chills that their children pets
and other things they found important I
took an evaluation of the things I had
on me and thought to myself I didn't
know if I was if it was just a little
cooking fire or an entire apartment
consuming fire I don't think twice to
grab anything Allison on my wallet and I
might none of my camera gear so I'm a
photographer and videographer and
nothing when we were cleared to go back
in it was just an oven fire they put up
I took a long hard look around my room I
started questioning how valuable
although I'm Artie hello minimalists
this is Jessica from Long Beach
California and I have a comment for the
lady who says that her house with her
lawn is weighing her down here in
Southern California we've been in a
drought for an awfully long time and a
lot of the folks we know who have houses
with lawns ripped them out and replaced
them with drought tolerant plants and I
know that that's that is an investment
you know the the upfront cost of buying
all these plants and rocks and
whatever else you're using to landscape
but they're saving money on water and no
more mowing so that is pretty sweet if
you have that option it frees up some
time for a little bit of initial cost
upfront and you're helping the
environment a little bit all right Joe
that's it for this episode if you have a
question for the minimalists you can
give us a call for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also send
us an email a voice memo right from your
phone to podcast at the minimalists comm
and if you leave here with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listen y'all
we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got a have
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you'll be fine without your team
[Music]
you
[Music]